В ефірі випуск новин дня «heute 19 Uhr» з Мітрієм Зіріним.
Добрий вечір всім.
Крістін Отто розповість про новини спорту.
З радістю! Добрий вечір.
Теми сьогоднішнього випуску:
Партія Лівих переживає складні часи -
у серії «літніх інтерв'ю» на ZDF «ZDF-Sommerinterviews»
розмова з ﻿новим співголовою Лівих - Мартіном Шірдеваном.
Міністерка закордонних справ Бербок з візитом в Японії -
у Наґасакі Бербок виступає за світ без ядерної зброї.
Новак Джокович став семиразовим чемпіоном Вімблдону -
серб здобув 21-й титул на турнірі Grand Slam.
Через війну вартість життя помітно зросла.
Передусім від цього страждають
люди з низьким рівнем доходу,
які є цільовою групою потенційних виборців для Лівих,
що створює для партії несприятливу ситуацію.
Ліві зіштовхнулися з внутрішньополітичними проблемами
і невтішними результатами виборів.
Про те, як співголова Лівих Шірдеван планує
вивести партію з кризи,
він розповів у інтерв’ю серії «ZDF-Sommerinterviews».
Репортаж Даніеля Понтцена.
Шірдеван і надалі не підтримує поставки зброї в Україну.
І це попри те, що його дідуся у свій час врятували
бронетанкові сили США.
Я підтримував звʼязок з дідусем.
Ми часто проводили час разом
та дискутували на різні теми.
Я не вважаю себе
радикальним пацифістом.
Але я, як і приблизно 40% населення Німеччини,
розумію ризики ескалації цієї війни.
Німеччині загрожують проблеми з постачанням енергоносіїв,
але Шірдеван відкидає використання «Північного потоку-2».
Про використання газопроводу нещодавно говорив
глава комітетуіз захисту клімату та енергетики партії Лівих Клаус Ернст.
Ернст згодом дав розʼяснення своїм словам.
Але хто, як не він - голова комітету енергетики -
буде говорити про енергетичну безпеку.
Про проблему, яка турбує суспільство.
Як нафтове ембарго вплине
на добробут регіону поблизу міста Шведт?
Адже тамтешні працівники ще досі не отримали
жодних гарантій від уряду Німеччини.
Також Шірдеван розраховує
на співпрацю провідних представників партії,
щоб спільно відстоювати погляди й переконання.
Включаючи Сару Ваґенкнехт,
яка гостро критикувала обрання нового дуету лідерів партії.
Це, безперечно, питання «стилю»,
хто і як сприймає демократичні рішення,
ухвалені на зʼїздах партії.
Це кожен вирішує для себе.
- Але...
- Йдеться не про злам і розкол,
а про злагоджену роботу тих,
хто несе відповідальність.
Він і співголова Лівих Жанін Віслер готові
до інтенсивної співпраці з фракцією.
Що вони й робили протягом останніх двох тижнів.
Продовження інтерв’ю з Мартіном Шірдеваном
Ви можете переглянути одразу після нашого випуску новин,
а також у додатку ZDFheute.
У разі дефіциту та подорожчання енергії
міністерка захисту прав споживачів Лемке хоче гарантувати
захист споживачів,
яким через неспроможність оплатити рахунки
можуть відключити газ і електроенергію.
У інтервʼю виданню «Bild am Sonntag» міністерка повідомила,
що у разі кризи варто буде погодити ще один пакет допомоги.
Уряд Німеччини зітхнув з полегшенням,
оскільки Канада погодила передачу відремонтованої турбіни
для газопроводу «Північний потік-1».
Декілька тижнів тому Росія зменшила постачання газу
газопроводом «Північний потік-1»,
обґрунтовуючи це з-поміж іншого також відсутністю турбіни.
За даними, завтра розпочнуться
роботи з планового технічного ремонту газопроводу,
тож газопровід не використовуватиметься, попередньо 10 днів.
А зараз до актуальних подій війни в Україні.
Російські війська знову обстріляли
Схід України.
Ракета влучила у багатоповерхівку у Часовому Ярі на Донеччині.
За українськими даними, виявлено не менше 15 загиблих
та багато поранених.
Рятувальники продовжують пошуки вцілілих під завалами.
Напружені дні для міністерки закордонних справ
Анналени Бербок.
Після візиту на Балі та Палау
Бербок прибула до Японії.
Це - як балансування на канаті, непроста зустріч.
Напередодні вбили експрем'єр-міністра Сіндзо Абе,
а сьогодні в Японії проходили вибори до Верхньої палати парламенту.
Міністерка навідалася до Наґасакі та виступала
за світ без ядерної зброї.
Репортаж Ульфа Ролера.
В Європі вирує війна.
Жахіття минулого відчуваються тут
особливо гостро.
Об 11:03 вибухнула атомна бомба над Наґасакі.
Миттєво загинуло близько 22 тис. осіб.
Сьогодні загроза світової війни знову реальна.
Заклик Бербок залишиться непочутим?
І хоча минули десятиліття, але Наґасакі й Хіросіма
і досі є нагадуванням того, що ми всі разом маємо
боротися за світ без ядерної зброї,
навіть якщо цей шлях ще дуже довгий.
Міністерка відвідала Музей атомної бомби в Наґасакі
та зустрілася з паном Танакою.
Він вижив, а його родина загинула від наслідків ядерної радіації.
Його послання політики ще жодного разу так і не виконали.
«Насильство не принесе мир, - пояснює пан Танака, -
тільки переговори й дипломатія».
Бербок подорожує країною, яка все більше озброюється.
Японія також переживає час історичних змін.
Прагнення Росії та Китаю до влади є
прямою загрозою цілісності Японії.
Більшість населення підтримує модернізацію армії,
щоб підвищити обороноздатність країни.
Наразі пацифізм для Японії не актуальний.
«Товстун» - назва атомної бомби, що була скинута на Наґасакі.
На її фоні міністерка виглядає маленькою.
Сучасні атомні бомби набагато руйнівніші,
а їхня кількість збільшилася.
Місяцями не вистачало газу, електроенергії,
ліків та інших товарів першої необхідності.
Це найгостріша економічна криза на Шрі-Ланці
від дня проголошення країною незалежності у 1948 році.
Як наслідок - населення повстало.
Президент оголосив про відставку.
Учора протестувальники штурмували резиденцію президента.
У столиці Коломбо спочатку був хаос,
згодом можна було бачити подекуди сюрреалістичні сцени.
Про події останніх 48 годин розповість Лютен Лейнгос.
Перше затишшя після бурі - напрочуд мирне.
Після місяців часто кривавих протестів
люди хочуть відчути смак розкоші у президентській резиденції.
Я хочу побачити, на що витрачалися наші податки.
Я учасник протестного руху.
Політики повинні розуміти силу народу.
Вони планують залишатися в резиденції,
допоки президент Раджапакса
справді не піде з посади.
Більше ніж 100 000 громадян вийшли вчора на вулиці Коломбо.
Вони протестували проти найгіршої економічної кризи в країні.
Щоб зупинити натовп поліція застосовувала все:
водомети, попереджувальні постріли та сльозогінний газ.
Та марно.
Вся влада належить народу! Ось так!
В останню хвилину президенту
вдалося дістатися до корабля та втекти.
Раджапакса підтвердив,
що офіційно піде у відставку цієї середи.
Правління сімейної династії Раджапакса та його брата
розпочалося 2005 року.
Шрі-Ланка, зокрема численні релігійні й етнічні групи,
які довгий час відчайдушно боролися за свої права,
зараз переживають переломний момент.
Сьогодні ми неначе одна велика сімʼя.
Ми святкуємо справжню свободу.
Надія, яка надихає багатьох,
зокрема гостей пікніка, який організували
сьогодні на галявині президентської резиденції.
Південь Європи страждає від високих температур
і сильної посухи,
внаслідок яких виникають сильні лісові пожежі.
У Португалії постраждала територія між Порто та Лісабоном.
У ліквідації пожежі взяли участь
близько 2200 надзвичайників та пожежних літаків.
Сильний вітер підсилює полумʼя.
На хорватському півострові Істрія
пожежа перетворила на пустку 40 гектарів території.
Частина міста Пула тимчасово знеструмлена.
А тепер до спорту. Сьогодні, як і кожної неділі,
новин багато. Чи не так, Крістін?
- Безперечно!
Пілот «Феррарі» Шарль Леклер виграв Гран-прі Австрії в Шпільберзі,
перегнавши чемпіона світу Макса Ферстаппена
та рекордсмена Льюїса Гамільтона.
Проте справжньою зіркою дня став Мік Шумахер.
Сміливо обганяючи
свого партнера по «Хаасу» Кевіна Магнуссена,
Мік Шумахер справедливо посідає шосте місце та
цілком заслужено стає зіркою дня.
Те, що ми демонструємо зараз,
сподіваюсь, і в майбутніх гонках принесе нам
багато очок.
Макс Ферстаппен стартує бездоганно,
та згодом змушений поступитися сильнішому супернику -
Шарлю Леклеру з «Фераррі».
Прямо перед фінішем змусив всіх понервувати
пілот «Фераррі» Карлос Сайнс,
який в останні секунди виліз неушкодженим
зі свого боліда, що загорівся через несправність двигуна.
З 2013 року йому немає рівних.
Серб Новак Джокович вчетверте поспіль здобув
перемогу на турнірі Вімблдон.
Джокович обіграв у фіналі Ніка Киріоса в чотирьох сетах.
Новак Джокович - король англійських кортів.
Це сьома перемога серба на корті Вімблдону.
Перемозі посприяв і сам суперник Джоковича - австралієць Нік Киріос, який
часто заважав сам собі своїми
словесними перепалками, криками і претензіями.
Після програшу в першому сеті
Джокович відіграється і
реалізує на тай-брейку у четвертому сеті
свій третій матчбол.
Його 21 титул турніру Grand Slam має особливе значення.
Я обожнюю цей турнір всім серцем.
Він надихає мене продовжувати грати.
Переможний трофей йому вручила герцогиня Кейт -
наче коронація Новака Джоковича.
Велике досягнення молодої німецької веслярки.
Останній ривок приніс перемогу
20-річній Александрі Фюстер в одиночному запливі
на фіналі чемпіонату світу на озері Ротзее в Люцерні.
Єдина перемога флоту DRV.
Клуб гребців з Дортмунда посів третє місце.
На цьому у мене все.
Дякую, Крістін.
Перейдемо до прогнозу погоди.
Завтра на території від Північного моря
до Баварського лісу буде хмарно,
без опадів.
На інших територіях сонячно.
Стовпчики термометрів піднімуться до +18-23°, на
південному заході до +28°.
У сьогоднішньому випуску «heute journal»
о 21:45 з Марієттою Сломкою
поговоримо про спеку та посуху.
Бажаю вам спокійного недільного вечора
та запрошую до перегляду інтерв'ю «ZDF-Sommerinterviews»
зі співголовою партії Лівих Мартіном Шірдеваном.
Побачимося завтра.